The Joe Rogan Experience
so they're just setting up they may
fight
when they say he's not gonna fight him
in pfl
is that what he said yeah
Jake does have a pfl contract right
what's cool is Logan came up from the he
can be in WWE tonight and came over
dude look at Logan's outfit yeah it's
ridiculous
oh I don't see him fight Tommy Fury
she wants to Tommy for your rematch
you need to fight KSI the thing is it's
like if he wants to fight Nate in an MMA
fight and the pfl comes with that long
money who [__] knows you know he's
saying I want to do that pfl [__] but
what does he mean by that it's an MMA
fight
like is he just is he wanting to get
back to the UFC so he could fight Conor
McGregor so he fights Jake and then he
fights Connor because if he fights Conor
next that kind of still is valid correct
if Connor said I want to fight Nate Diaz
yeah it's so good that's still good and
I think it if he signs a deal with pfl
Daniel's gonna be like then you ain't
getting that Conor fight son
right
yeah probably
you know I mean I don't know but it's
it's interesting does Logan got
something lined up yeah what is he doing
he's having a fight uh him and ksr are
fighting on the same card yeah in
October yeah
and they haven't announced Logan's KSI
is about to get his ass KSI is fighting
Tommy Fury who is that dude who's KSI
he's a real famous YouTuber he's massive
in in England massive bigger boxes he's
got skills but Tommy furries I don't
know he doesn't have more skills than
Jake and Tommy Fury pieced up Jay right
you don't make a ton of sense wow what
was that a split decision you said
pieced up wasn't that a split decision
no I don't think it was split he just
said it was split really I think it was
split yeah Tom security definitely won
that fight I thought he won the fight
but it was a good fight yeah it was a
good solid fight yeah but the the money
makers Logan versus Jake and then Jake
versus KSI I don't know why he wants to
fight Tommy who gives a [__] bro I think
he just wants to get it back for his ego
I guess probably he said he said he
actually I think well the closed
captioning I read said he doesn't want
that he said that's on the drawing board
but he said he didn't want that oh good
for him oh I see